his space wave's the first feature
screenplay you've written yes wrote it
when I was 21. and before that I had
only written I think a nine page script
before and so I was just like all right
let's let's do a feature I didn't really
know what I was doing but I mean I think
I think that's what you have to do is uh
as a filmmakers just push yourself to do
harder things and um it's kind of funny
that when I was
when I when the producer and I started
this project I was like I don't know if
I'm ready to make a feature and he said
he said something I'll never forget he
was like dude nobody's ever ready to
make their first feature and that was
great advice you know we're never ready
it's just it's something that you choose
to
um just go for you know and as you do it
you know that's that's the um that's the
Proving Grounds you know and you met
your producer at Biola correct yeah nice
you know a summer class of uh
photography 2017 we're the only two guys
in the class and so and he was also a
film major so I'm like oh awesome you
know that was great what gave you the
confidence to know that you could do
this story you'd had the image in your
mind for sounds like many years of the
Tower yeah
um what gave me the confidence to do it
was just
I I had made like huge skateboarding
epic videos before so I had worked on a
couple of skateboarding videos for a
year and then one of them was two years
and both of those projects were like
over an hour long so they were they were
huge projects and you know I was filming
and I was the I had the vision I was The
Mastermind I'm like okay I'm gonna have
this for the intro and then I'm gonna do
this and this and this and this and I've
I was always gravitating towards Big
projects
um and so my roots as being a
skateboarder
um growing up the videos I watched were
all about like skateboarding teams that
were it was a close-knit team and they
would make videos and so then like each
skater would have like a full part video
part which would be like three minutes
of their skating and it would be like a
very structured thing and then as the
internet
um continued to grow and everything that
kind of full-length skate videos sort of
died down because then it became like oh
Escape Warriors would just film their
own part and then just release it online
and it'd be and so skateboarding became
less of
um a community Vibe for the
skateboarding videos and that was
something that really bothered me
um and I always wanted to be a part of
these projects where it's like oh
there's a group of guys and we're all
working towards a collective goal it's
not just like oh this guy's making his
own video part and this guy's making his
it's like I want to bring people
together for a common purpose and a
common goal
um and so in high school I was making
these skate videos and I was always you
know grabbing all my different friends
who were skaters and then a couple of my
other friends who weren't skaters and I
was like hey you should jump out of a
moving car for my Escape video or you
should jump off this building or we're
at this one party and I was like hey I'm
gonna film you like go up in front of
the crowd and like rip your shirt off
and stuff and like just trying to be as
wild and as fun as possible and so I
would make the escape videos in high
school and they were like I said big
like over an hour plus long like
skateboarding epics you know and so that
was always my mindset
um and when I got to film school I
really didn't like short films because I
every time I was making a short film I'm
like well this is just gonna be
forgotten about or this isn't you know
it's not big enough whatever and I'm
always thinking so big and so I made a
handful of short films um and they went
pretty well and I definitely
um thankful I had the opportunity to
make short films and to learn turn
because I think short films are really
great for Learning and experimenting and
stuff but then it came to a point where
I just didn't want to make shorts and I
wanted to make the big project and so I
just you know grabbed all my friends and
was like hey I'm trying to make this big
movie trying to make space waves and
just brought everyone together and yeah
I mean we didn't really know what we
were doing but we just had a dream and
we pursued it and it and it worked out
very happy with it yeah did anybody say
don't make your like dream project like
practice on another feature first no no
one said that but people always did say
don't make a feature in general I mean
it's
it's um I mean most people that tried
just fail you know it's so it's so
insanely hard and you know I don't know
if I would have gone through it had I
known it would have been a five-year
process you know that's like just such a
commitment it's so much time it's so
much work it's so much money invested so
if you are going to do a feature I say
like just go do the feature that you
have burning deep inside of you that you
have to that you have to make you know
um and I always I always like to say to
um write the movie you want to see
within the parameters of the story you
need to tell
can we talk about the beginning process
of writing the screenplay
um yeah I mean the beginning process way
back in 2017 was just
um I spent the summer kind of just
reflecting on my growing up and trying
to pick out the significant moments that
I felt like really Illustrated the story
um
so that the argument scene in space
waves that was a moment that kind of
um I didn't necessarily have that
argument with that friend face to face
but all of the things said and done in
that scene were just kind of a
collection of thoughts and feelings and
things that we had gone through and so I
was like oh this feeling or this thing
that he said or I said whatever I'm
gonna grab all these different pieces
try to fit them together in this scene
or that scene
and then also it was just like you know
the first half of space waves is all
about just the fun and the adventures
and stuff and so I I figured okay let me
just reach back into my mind and grab
some of the fun and the adventures that
me and my friends had while growing up
and so I would put those into the film
and it was also just one of those things
where it's like hey what do I want to
see how about we have a flash mob
incident or how about we have the
characters wandering through the forest
looking for a phoenix statue and then it
ends up being a chicken and like just
kind of being fun and being random and
the producer and I would just bounce
wild ideas off of each other and this
was this was a movie that thrived on
um just yeah the wildness and the
randomness and just uh it's got a very
like specific brand of comedy and just a
brand of fun that um that we really that
we really like so you were in college at
Biola yeah 2017. did you miss home is
that what tied you thinking about high
school no well
I I'm a very nostalgic person so I think
about the past a lot whether that be to
like to analyze it and to learn and grow
from it or because there's just kind of
a comfort in the past because it's known
whereas the future is just completely
unknown but like in the past there's a
lot of beautiful memories there's a lot
of painful memories and there's just a
lot to digest there and I'm a I'm a very
sentimental person so I like to take a
lot of photos take a lot of videos
journal and all that kind of stuff
how did you structure the writing of the
movie
so the way I structured the movie was
that I wanted the first half to be
um more of the comedy side because space
waves is like a comedy drama so the
first half is very comedic very fun it's
all daytime and then the second half is
very dramatic and Moody and it's all
night time and kind of the fun isn't at
nearly as present and so that
juxtaposition really serves the movie
well because the first half has so much
content of like the podcast and all this
explosive energy and the pacing is
really fast and there's just all this
stuff going on and like constant you
know funny one-liners and just a lot of
jokes and a lot of things happening kind
of Rapid Fire and then the second half
there's a real absent there's a real
absence of the podcast and so you feel
that absence
um and so then it's just kind of Marvin
the main character on his own dealing
with things and it's like oh well
where's his best friend Joey where's the
podcast it's not really there anymore so
who is he and what is he without the pot
podcast and without his best friend and
so another thing we did was put a bunch
of podcast narrations in the first half
of the film
so as the scenes are happening and stuff
you'll hear the space waves podcast just
kind of overlaid over some of the scenes
and stuff and so then like I said the
second half of the movie that that is
totally gone and so it really is a big
contrast and so the second half of the
movie feels much different than the
first half and I think that really just
helps Drive the point home and helps us
communicate the message better that like
what do you do once you lose your best
friend because it really is such a
different it's such a different vibe you
know the first half to the second half
and and his purpose too right yeah
because the podcast stops yeah I don't
want to give spoilers away I mean yeah
it's it's
um it's you know halfway through the
film the podcast does stop and so
um that is the main kind of one of the
main themes in the film it's like what
do you do when your friends are going
separate ways and the thing you worked
for and you know poured your life into
is no more or it's at a standstill or
it's at a pause you know who are you
then and so the main character Marvin
just had his whole identity wrapped up
in the podcast and in his friendship
with Joey and when that's not going
right and that's not nearly as present
in his life anymore
um yeah he's got a lot of thinking to do
and he's got a lot of pain that he's
dealing with and so the second half of
the film really just goes through and
shows all of that
all of the characters arcs
um tried to yeah I think
I think so I mean
Duke Duke Skylander has a really great
Arc he's the he's the third character
and um
he's a character that you don't
necessarily think has much depth to him
because he's very much kind of the
um the comedic relief and he's kind of
the you know the Third Wheel in the
Buddy comedy whatever and so he's making
his his magnum opus like skate video
called hourglass existence and at the
beginning of the film you just think oh
this guy is you know he's just um he's
just this wild ridiculous character but
then in the second half of the film you
see that he's actually very insecure and
he's like oh man I'm not sure if
anyone's gonna come to my film Premiere
I don't even know if my film is good
enough and stuff and then Marvin the
main character is able to come in and be
a good friend to Duke you know
um and so he's able to be that good
friend even though he feels like he
doesn't have that good friend to his own
life so we try to give we tried to give
it a character Arc to Duke and we tried
to give character arcs to all the
different characters
um but yeah it's kind of a tough
Balancing Act
um just in general
but I think we did pretty well with that